let's speak to the meteorologist at the
met office claire mercier who joins us
now claire lovely to see you um how hot
is it gonna get this week
well you've just said it actually neil
are 34 degrees by friday across slaves
of england and wales and warm also for
northern ireland as well as scotland but
here a little bit more unsettled towards
the northwest but really the high heat
the intensity which could be oppressive
for many people will be reserved for the
southeastern quadrant of the country
where through the next few days
temperatures are just going to keep
going up
and of course it could get quite
dangerous look north of the border in
scotland i've seen men with their tops
off when the temperature reaches 15
degrees down here people tend to be a
little bit more sensible but when it's
reaching a size 24 25 26 lots of people
will be out in the sun and they need to
take care don't they
oh absolutely i mean we're really not
used to the heat here and actually a
comfortable temperature is in the 20s
when we see temperatures exceeding 30
degrees celsius it's they're they're
warning signs and as you say uv levels
at the moment are high we reach maximum
solar radiation on the 21st of june
summer solstice and so we're sort of
pushing towards that at the moment so
yes uv levels are high if you're heading
to the beach
you know the reflection of the sand and
the sea light surfaces reflects uv so
you can burn even quicker so it's really
just be aware practice a safe sun enjoy
the sunshine because you know that
summer doesn't last very long to be
honest it's three months
meteorologically and
just be aware that particularly for
people who are vulnerable with breathing
difficulties who perhaps are living on
their own don't have many green spaces
where they live it's worth just keeping
an eye and keeping a check on them
drinking lots of water staying hydrated
and embracing the sun where you can
early mornings later on in the
afternoons but it's worth noting also
that pollen counts are going to be very
high across england and wales
high across scotland and northern
ireland so we've got a lot of highs to
deal with over the next few days neil
yeah i was going to say as someone who
suffers from the hay fever yeah you
didn't need to tell me that uh i will be
slapping on the factor 50 when i leave
the studio however claire anderson
lovely to see you thanks for joining us